♪ ♪
>> SO AS OF LAST NIGHT, 200
INMATES FROM OUR JAIL SYSTEM
HAVE BEEN RELEASED.
THAT ACTION LAST NIGHT ALLOWED
US TO HIT A MAJOR, MAJOR
MILESTONE, AND NONE OF US
EXPECTED THIS CRISIS, BUT ONE
THING THAT HAS COME OUT OF IT IS
OUR JAIL POPULATION CONTINUES TO
DECLINE.
>> Martha: SO THAT’S
NEW YORK CITY
MAYOR BILL de BLASIO TOUTING
THE RELEASE OF HUNDREDS OF
PRISONERS AS PART OF AN EFFORT
TO COMBAT THE SPREAD OF THE
VIRUS.
THIS IS A TREND HAPPENING IN
CITIES AND COUNTIES ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
IN NEW JERSEY, HUNDREDS OF LOW
IMPACT -- "LOW IMPACT,
NONVIOLENT OFFENDERS," HAVE BEEN
RELEASED IN ORDER TO PREVENT THE
SPREAD OF THIS DISEASE.
SEAN BOLDEN IS THE MAYOR OF
MONMOUTH COUNTY AND JOINS ME NOW
SHERIFF, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING ME TONIGHT.
PHIL MURPHY, THE GOVERNOR OF
NEW JERSEY, CALLED THIS A
GROUNDBREAKING PROGRAM.
DO YOU CONSIDER THIS A
GROUNDBREAKING PROGRAM?
>> WELL, LISTEN, IF YOU CAN
CONSIDER GROUNDBREAKING WHEN YOU
RELEASE INMATES RESISTING ARREST
AND SOME SEX OFFENSES, FAILURE
TO REGISTER FOR SEX OFFENDER
OFFENSES.
THEN I GUESS YOU COULD CALL IT
GROUNDBREAKING.
BUT LISTEN COME ACROSS THE STATE
OF NEW JERSEY, WE RECEIVED A
LETTER FROM THE ACLU ON THE
20TH, IN ORDER TO SHOW CAUSE
IMMEDIATELY IN THE COURTS, FAST
TRACKED OVER THE WEEKEND.
BY THE 23RD, WE HAD TO HAVE A
LIST OF OFFENDERS "LOW IMPACT,
NONVIOLENT OFFENDERS" COME TO
BE RELEASED OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE.
IF YOU’RE IN MONMOUTH COUNTY,
6400 IN A STATE OF NEW JERSEY,
AND YOU LOOK AT THE LIST THAT
HAS SOME OF THOSE OFFENSES ON
IT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS ABSURD TO
RELEASE INMATES STILL FULFILLING
A SENTENCE OF WHERE
LAW ENFORCEMENT, INJURED IN
PARTICULAR CASES, ONE ASSAULT,
THROWING FLUIDS AND A
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER,
RESISTING ARREST.
FAILURE TO REGISTER
SEX OFFENDERS, AND I’M SHOWING
YOU RELEASE THEM COME IN A
SARCASTIC WAY, THEY WENT OUT AND
REGISTERED, MARTHA.
THIS IS AN EXPLOITATION OF A
POLICY THAT CERTAINLY, YOU KNOW,
WAS PUSHED WITH AN AGENDA, AND
RAPIDLY THROUGH THE
SUPREME COURT IN NEW JERSEY.
>> Martha: ALL RIGHT, SO RIGHT
NOW, DO THESE FACILITIES HAVE
COVID-19 OUTBREAKS PROBLEMS?
>> HERE’S THE THING.
OUR FACILITY DOES NOT.
WE HAVE NO POSITIVE TEST CASES,
WE HAVE TWO IN QUARANTINE AND
ISOLATION IN A DIFFERENT POP.
WE CALL POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
WEEKS AGO, LIKE OTHER JAILS
DATED AROUND THE STATE OF
NEW JERSEY, NOT ALLOWING
VISITATION AND GOING TO VIDEO
REVISITATION AND PHONE CALLS FOR
THE INMATES, HAVING SPECIAL
VISITATION FOR THEIR ATTORNEYS.
CHECKING THEM OUTSIDE WITH
TEMPERATURES AND ASSESSMENTS
BEFORE WE BRING THEM INSIDE, AND
WHEN WE BRING THEM INSIDE THEY
END UP IN A SECOND POD IN
QUARANTINE FOR 14 WEEKS.
THE THING HERE, NONE OF THE
OTHER LOCAL JAILS, SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION, NONE WERE CONSULTED
BEFORE THIS EVEN WENT TO, AND
LUCKILY, THE PROSECUTORS HAD A
CONTEST PEAK WHERE THEY COULD
CONTEST SOME OF THESE MATES
BEING RELEASED INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
>> Martha: I THINK THAT IS
AMAZING, AND YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT THE FACT THERE’S
GOING TO BE A LOT OF PRESSURE ON
COMMUNITIES WITH A LOT OF ISSUES
THAT ARE GOING ON WITH THIS
VIRUS AND ALSO WITH THE ECONOMY,
IT SEEMS LIKE A DIFFICULT TIME.
A PRETTY GOOD SYSTEM IN PLACE.
>> IN ONE CASE, WE HAD A
RELEASE, ARRESTED FOR
SHOPLIFTING THEFT ON WEDNESDAY.
THIS IS WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE,
AND CERTAINLY A DRAIN ON OUR
RESOURCE TO WORRY ABOUT THIS
DURING THIS CRISIS.
IT’S DEFINITELY AN EXPLOITATION,
SO.
THANK YOU TO ALL OF OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS.
>> Martha: GOOD TO HAVE YOU
WITH US, AND THANK YOU TO ALL OF
OUR FOLKS ON THE FRONT LINES IN